one of the things that they do is if
someone dares step out of you know
what's politically acceptable at that
moment they usually will call you far
right or alt-right or something like
that I've been through this over the
years I've often told you about that
Sunday about four years ago when my dad
went to get coffee at the bagel place
that he's been going to for 30 years
that he picks up the New York Times and
there's a front page Sunday article
about how me and Jordan Peterson and
Milton Friedman and Ben Shapiro are the
leaders of the alt-right and my face
giant picture of my face I think on page
three of the New York Times it was a
shock to him he did not know it I had to
admit it after it was the whole thing
anyway one of the things they do is they
lie about your political connections so
this is really interesting so Washington
Post listen to what they wrote about the
Twitter Files The Dump of Twitter files
that have just come out as head of trust
and safety at Twitter Roth this is this
guy yoel Roth
was involved in many of the platform's
decisions about what posts to remove and
what accounts to suspend his
Communications with other Twitter
Twitter officials has been posted in
recent days as part of what must cause
the Twitter files a series of tweets by
conservative journalists Matt taibi and
Barry Weiss okay so this is actually
extraordinary I know it doesn't surprise
you guys but Matt taibi has been a lefty
Progressive his whole life he worked at
The Intercept with Glenn Greenwald I
think he is having a little red pill
moment and kind of coming
to Jesus kind of thing like it is
happening but by no stretch is he a
conservative I certainly don't think the
guys let's say pro-life I have no idea
what he feels about the welfare state or
or immigration or anything but no one in
an honest assessment could call this guy
conservative and Barry Weiss was at the
New York Times her whole life she still
is a liberal uh I think I have no doubt
that she only votes for Democrats as
misguided as that might be and only
surrounds herself really with Democrats
but she's a conservative because she's
going because the the paper The
Washington Post wants to turn Their
audience against these people they want
you to be suspicious of these people
because Elon Musk did not give the
Twitter files to Washington Post he gave
it to them well after enough outrage and
enough tweets about it uh The Washington
Post changed it uh and they've removed
the word conservative of course they did
not issue a correction or post that on
Twitter so you get what they do and
again this is exactly why they need to
censor everybody because the Washington
Post wants to be able to lie
about the people who are just delivering
you the information and they don't want
you to be able to call them out for it
but fortunately now that elon's got
Twitter enough people can do it and they
issue well they I suppose it's not
issuing a correction they've removed the
lie but then they don't issue an actual
correction